These giant tech companies
have so much power.
Big Tech poses the single greatest threat
to free speech in our country today.
So much economic power
and so much political power.
Everywhere you turn these days,
Big Tech companies are under fire.
Instagram's supposedly
addictive and negative effects
on teenage girls have lawmakers comparing
its parent company,
Facebook, to Big Tobacco.
Conservatives like Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
and Texas Governor Greg Abbott
have signed controversial legislation
banning social media platforms
from moderating content
and kicking off users
for political reasons.
Supreme Court Associate
Justice Clarence Thomas
has said businesses
like Twitter and YouTube
should be subject to
strict federal regulation.
Liberal legislators in Colorado
have proposed creating a digital
communications commission
that would have the power
to change how platforms do business
in the name of fighting hate
speech and misinformation.
Lawmakers in at least 38
states have introduced
over a hundred laws in
the past couple of years
to regulate online speech
and business practices.
In his new book, Tech
Panic, Reason's Robby Soave
says such attacks are
modern-day witch hunts
that fall apart under even mild scrutiny.
They're the contemporary
version of past freakouts
over video games, rock
music and comic books.
We shouldn't fear Facebook
or the future, writes Soave.
The actual threat, he says,
comes not from private companies,
but from politicians, woke
mobs, social conservatives
and activists whose real goal
is to limit speech they don't like.
Robby Soave.
Thanks for talking.
My pleasure.
Give me the elevator pitch of Tech Panic:
Why We Shouldn't Fear
Facebook and the Future.
Sure.
Panic about social media
is very popular right now.
It's bipartisan.
It's crossed all over
the ideological spectrum.
People as different as
Elizabeth Warren and Josh Hawley
and Joe Biden and Donald Trump
all think we need to do something,
the government needs to do
something about social media,
about Big Tech.
My book argues no, that's wrong.
The concerns are overstated.
The solutions that these
people offer are very bad,
from a range of not fixing the problems
that they're talking about
to they'll make things worse
to the problems they're talking
about aren't even problems.
So I get into all the various,
the most popular panics
about social media and discuss
to the extent they're true
and what should be done about them.
Okay, so we'll go through them
and we're gonna come to things
like Section 230
and antitrust actions against Big Tech.
But first, you know, the
kind of panic du jour,
which came up in a big way
after the book was printed,
has to do with Facebook and Instagram
having a terrible negative effect,
particularly on young girls.
This is Instagram.
A report came out, The Wall
Street Journal talked it up
about Instagram and Facebook researchers
had looked at the platform itself
and said, oh my God, Instagram
is driving young girls
to anorexia and worse.
What is wrong about that?
Right.
So it looks to me like Facebook
has come up with some
internal data showing
a mild
increase in
feelings of depression
or not being good enough
or not being pretty enough
among teenage girls.
I think their figure was a third
of their teenage female users
were experiencing heightened depression
because of Instagram.
The idea being that Instagram
is showing you more,
in the search feature,
it's curating for you
a feed of images based on things
you've been interested in.
So you're gonna see more
makeup, more models,
more pretty people.
Also Instagram itself is this
kind of deceptive medium,
where you're seeing the
best, the most glamorous,
the most attractive version of everyone
and that can lead to
feelings of insecurity
about your own appearance, et cetera.
So I think from looking at
and I looked at a lot of
other data for this book,
if you wanna say, there are reasons to be,
we should be concerned.
You know, we should keep studying this.
It might be having a negative
effect on some teenagers.
Absolutely.
I think that could very well be the case
and we should continue
to look at these things.
The idea that there's some
broad, insurmountable problem
for the vast majority
of social media users
does not seem well-founded.
You can cherry pick
this data a lot of ways.
For every statistic
about how teenage girls
have become more anxious
or more unhappy in the last 10 years,
you can find one showing that,
well, this other category
of social media user hasn't.
It's really hard to measure these things.
Some of the data looks to me like
the users who use social media
too much or extreme all day
have some bad mental health outcomes,
but so do the teens who don't
use social media at all.
The ones who are not, who are loners,
who are not connected with their friends.